the continuous function f is defined on
the interval negative 4 is less than or
equal to X is less than or equal to 3
the graph of f consists of two quarter
circles and one line segment so this
right here is one quarter circle then we
have another quarter circle and then it
has this line segment over here as shown
in the figure above I put the figure on
the side so that we have some screen
real estate down here let G of X be
equal to 2x plus the definite integral
from 0 to X of F of T DT all right
that's a little bit interesting now
let's do Part A Part A find G of
negative 3 so we want to find G of
negative 3 so first of all they tell us
what G of X is so G of negative 3 every
time we see an X we just put a negative
3 there so is going to be 2 times
negative 3 2 times negative 3 plus the
definite integral from 0 to negative 3 F
of T F of T DT so this first part is
pretty straightforward 2 times negative
3 is negative 6 and then this part right
over here is the definite integral from
0 to negative 3 of F of T DT so from 0
to negative 3 f of T DT so this is
essentially this is essentially the area
under under F of T or under f of X if
you want to view it that way from 0 to 3
and this is pretty straight forward to
figure out but we have to be careful
here
because this area this area right over
here this would be the integral let me
do this in a color that you can see that
area right over there
would be the integral from negative 3 to
0 F of f of T or we can use a F of T DT
or f of X DX either way DT that would be
this area right over here they've
swapped it they have the larger number
as the lower bound they have 0 as the
lower bound so what we could do this we
could rewrite this this is the same
thing this is equal to negative 6 minus
if you swap the bounds of integration
you swap the sign on the integral so we
could say minus from negative 3/2 is
zero of F of T DT and now this thing
right over here this expression right
over here is the area it is the area
under this quarter circle and the area
under this quarter circle we can just
use a little bit of geometry to figure
that out we know it's radius the radius
here is three radius is equal to three
the entire circle is PI R squared so the
entire circle the area if this was an
entire circle right over here if this
was an entire circle that area would be
PI R squared so pi times three squared
so nine pi so it would be nine PI but
this is only one-fourth of the entire
circle so we want to divide it by four
so this right over here will evaluate to
nine PI over four so Part A we get it's
equal to negative six that's that right
over there minus nine PI minus nine PI
over four and that's at least the first
part of Part A then they say find G
prime of X so let's find G prime of X so
G prime of X we did the first part of
Part A right over there then we need to
find G prime of X G prime of X well it's
just going to be the derivative of G of
X the derivative of 2x is just going to
be two and then the derivative and this
is the fundamental theorem of calculus
right over here the derivative of the
definite integral from 0 to X of F of T
DT that's just going to be f of X that
is just going to be f of X so that is G
prime of X we did this second part right
over there that is G prime of X and then
we need to evaluate it at negative 3 so
G prime of negative 3 G prime of
negative 3 is going to be equal to 2
plus F of negative 3 which is equal to 2
plus and let's look at our let's see
what F of negative 3 is this is our
function definition when X is equal to
negative 3 our function is at 0 so f of
negative 3 is just 0 so it's just 2 plus
0 which is equal to 2 so G of negative 3
is equal to 2 and we're done with Part A
and the trickiest part of this is just
real
the bounds of integration that you might
be tempted to say oh the integral
between 0 and negative 3 that's just
this area over here because we're in
between 0 and negative 3 but you got to
realize that we actually have to swap
them and make them negative if you
really want to consider this area right
over here that this integral is going to
be the negative of this area and that's
what we did when we went to this step
right over there